i gotta ask now i just reminded me have
you guys ever gone fool karen have you
guys ever needed to like ask for the
manager
i don't think so he don't answer that
i could i could legitimately say no but
of course the entire [ __ ] audience is
going to be like
but like legitimately no i haven't cause
like i'm not the kind of person to like
go to a restaurant and be like my soup
is 20 minutes late yeah yeah
i feel like i normally try to like
i when i'm talking in those situations i
only try to build up some rapport with
the person i'm talking about yeah yeah
they'll normally be like yo listen uh
you know i nothing can be done and i'll
be like i mean i'll take your word for
it yeah yeah like you know i feel
there's like if there is a problem with
some kind of service or you know
situation
there's only so much that i know the
manager can do anyway so i'm just like
don't just don't even bother like yeah
i'll just i'll fault i don't give a [ __ ]
like it's not it's not a life or death
situation in that situation i i'd be
tempted to but even then i'm like i'm so
lazy that i'm like all right i guess i
also don't want to cause a scene you
know even though i'm perfectly in the
right to cause a scene because i'm the
one getting [ __ ] over like there's a
part there's a part of me that's just
like no i don't wanna i don't wanna like
be the [ __ ] yeah you know so it's
like yeah i don't know i don't think
i've ever
done but i mean i don't think like i
don't know it's weird because like if
you cause a scene sometimes you get what
you want yeah yeah right because it's
like i don't i just rather not i've been
in situations treat me like a human
being yeah yeah i've been in situations
where i've been in like a restaurant or
whatever and i've seen someone else
cause a scene
they get what they want yeah i'm just
like what an [ __ ] yeah yeah
because the thing is like it's it's
because i i
hardly ever go for karen um but i've
seen i've seen it work i just like i
could
i i don't have the ability to do that
myself yes because i remember like on
this trip back to england uh
there was this point where we were on
we're on a night out
uh we were with all our friends right um
and sydney was tired and so like i i
took her home like took her home like
earlier everyone else went on drinking
and eventually they ended up in a casino
right yeah
and so i was like cool i'm not tired yet
i'm is it cool if i go out to you know
continue with my mates and continue
drinking and have fun and then i was
like yeah sydney was already past us i
was like cool i'm just gonna go
please make noise
and so there was a sizeable group um
inside the casino yeah uh so i get there
and i want to go in and uh there's a
bouncer at the door uh and he's just
like sorry you can't come in unless you
remember and i was just like but
i know you've let uh plenty of other
people in because my entire my entire
friend group is in there yeah um and uh
my my friend group was in there and they
weren't members uh so what's that what's
happening with that and he was like oh
you know uh he was like sorry no members
right now uh
no entry right now until unless you
remember yeah and i was just like oh i i
know like
i know he can let me in you know like
it's not like a massive casino and the
thing is i see people walking out you
know i see like plenty of people walking
out
and
i like you know when you can tell like
that there's a bouncer who just wants to
go on a power trip oh yeah
like you know what i mean you know what
i mean
i like i knew it wasn't like it wasn't
like the vote like it wasn't like the
busiest place in london whatever it was
it was it was a place that i knew the
bouncer was just trying to be an [ __ ]
because like i could clearly see there
were people walking in and out yeah
right and there are people that were
going out and saying that they were
leaving and so i was just like okay what
is the right angle to go for to try and
get myself in right
because you want to see your friends
yeah because i because i've read because
i'm like i really want to see my friends
uh because the night we wasn't even like
that late
um and it was like a saturday or
something like was it a saturday or
like a tuesday um i believe it was a
sunday huh i could understand maybe it
was saturday it was really busy you know
they maybe want to limit it to customers
they know we're going to spend a [ __ ]
ton of money yeah it wasn't even like
that busier right no it was it wasn't
even that big so it's just being yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah because
because it's because like so i'm like
i'm like okay i gotta at least try to
get in right yeah because uh
if i don't get in i gotta i didn't get
to say goodbye to my friends and like my
night's over so i'm gonna at least like
try to get in uh and of course i don't
go for karen
i go i try to go for 25 percent
so i go i go for the friendly approach
you know like i start from like the
moment one right yeah the the rapport
approach right the the rapport approach
the daidus approach
there's nothing wrong with like being
like trying to explain like yeah you
know maybe if there's not like a giant
line behind you like listen i wanna i
wanna see my friends yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
calmly explained yeah situation
like be like look mate like i understand
that you don't want like a big group of
like strangers coming in or whatever at
this time of the hour you know i get
that you know you you're just like you
got you got some rules that you need to
follow and everything like that um look
i'll be honest i'm just one guy i'm not
local around here because i've literally
flown in from japan just to hang out
with my mates and i don't get this
chance often yeah um and i was i was you
know i was just like the sympathy
approach because i was because i was
like dude i'm not here to like ruin your
life
[ __ ] money yeah
you know i i know you just don't want
some [ __ ] random [ __ ] just like
walking in and everything like that i am
not that random ticket i'm not drunk you
know i'm i'm like i'm like a good i'm a
good boy i'm a good boy okay
yeah that's very well yeah yeah it's
very very well definitely like like i
was trying to be as well [ __ ] spoken
as possible it was this was like me me
like to putting on like the tuxedo like
it's the 100 speech 100 but like
but like [ __ ] you know this guy just was
not having it like he was like sometimes
like that they're just like you know she
was like no they're not having that
because because the thing is he would
not even like even have a conversation
like he was like no i can't i can get it
because they probably deal with like
some really [ __ ] awful things i i get
it i get it at the same time it's like
sometimes you're like yeah dude i'm i'm
i'm not i'm not the problem here dude
yeah yeah yeah the one causing you
problems yeah yeah yeah yes maybe i am
by talking to you too much yeah yeah
exactly i was just like look look you
know i and eventually i was just like
you know finding you know fine
i guess you know i guess i guess my
night's over and then one of my one of
my friends comes out right
and uh she sees what's going on she's
like what's going on here and i was like
they have some rules and
um the bouncer's just like not
communicating with me at all i don't
think there's any way to get in and
she's like
bet
she's like
karen mode active all
like there was like an instant like 50
like an instant switch to be like
um excuse me yeah like do you know that
he's getting married in a month
do you know who he is
he's the anime zone
the greatest youtuber and she goes and
and she's able to just like go on this
like some somehow yeah she's guys
probably want to get rid of her yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's [ __ ] off it's
like this [ __ ] five minute rant right
it's like you know it's it's like you
know uh when like senator armstrong's
just like standing there and like ryan
is just like [ __ ] like pulling the
punches and he's just
yeah he's not budging but like after
about five minutes she's just like
fine you can go in i was like that
worked that worked i i thought i thought
being like the nice guy would work but
just like [ __ ] like going like just
like no like just going full karen and
just like like calling for the manager
and just like not letting up that works
sometimes that's but i think that's the
thing right it's like i think the reason
why i don't go karen mode like ever is
because i've been on the other side of
that before like when i used to work oh
yeah yeah yeah and like oh my god i
still remember this [ __ ] to this day
but like it was it was this absolute
knob head who like he came in i was
working when i was working up at the ski
fields i was working behind a bar yeah
some nights and you know i had to pour
like beers and [ __ ] and whatever yeah
but then of course there's this [ __ ]
this [ __ ] walks in with like 10 of
his mates right and he was like and he
said
can you come here for a second yeah you
always were saying i was like oh you're
talking to me all right yeah whatever
that's a bit weird and uh and then he's
like can we get 20 b-52s please
and to explain what a b-52 is
it's this liqueur shot
that's three layers right yeah and so
the layering [ __ ] i don't if you've ever
made layering stuff you gotta like
slowly pour it at the back of a spoon
otherwise it mixes right yeah so in
other words making one of these takes a
long time yeah because you know you want
to make it look nice right and this
[ __ ] was like 20 of them please
and i was like
okay sure i was the only one at the bar
right yeah so i was like all right i
better start [ __ ] slaving away at it
then but you know because it's you know
a restaurant right and like a bar i want
it to like look nice i'm not just gonna
[ __ ] pour it in right yeah i start
pouring you know a couple of them and
then around like the third one that i'm
making this dk just walks into the bar
and he was like oh where the [ __ ] are
the b-52s
he's like get your manager and i was
like [ __ ] you wanna make it
you wanna be my guest be my guest ticket
make it right now you want to make it
any faster than me do you want them or
not you haven't even paid for it yet i
don't even have to make it for you
and so of course but you know that's
what i said in my head right but on the
outside i was like i'll get the manager
[Laughter]
so then i call the manager over and
she's like this japanese lady right but
like you know who looks really nice on
the outside but on the inside she's like
a reverse character because she has to
deal with like she has to deal with
[ __ ] like this right yeah so then
she comes out and you know this nice
like you know short japanese lady comes
out and she's like oh what seems to be
the problem and you know this guy starts
going off being like yeah so he's
[ __ ] taking forever making these
drinks you know like we've been waiting
forever by forever they mean like you
know 10 minutes yeah yeah right
and i've never seen someone go reverse
karen yeah on a customer before yeah and
she was just like um excuse me
do you want to make these
i don't think so so give him some
[ __ ] time
i love videos of like the employees of
fast food places yeah just being like
and and she was just like she literally
was like get out yeah good yeah
yeah and you know he was you know going
off and being like this is the worst
place ever [ __ ] you guys it's just like
i don't give a [ __ ] get out get the [ __ ]
out right now and i was like and you
know because i was like [ __ ] too shy
and like scared till i say anything so
in the back i was like yeah
so i've been in that situation before
yeah yeah so i think every time you know
i'm in a situation where you know
perhaps something is late or you know
where most people would want to go karen
mode in some situations i always
remember that situation i'm like no i
don't want to be that [ __ ] yeah i'll
wait because because like the part of
the reason that i was like because i got
like slightly annoyed at the bouncer
wasn't wasn't because of the fact that
he wasn't letting me in but because like
he just refused to like engage with me
yeah so because i wouldn't explain it to
you yeah he just wouldn't explain it to
me because like i could like i could
tell he was just like he he probably had
a bad day or something i don't [ __ ]
know but like he was just he just wanted
to exert his power upon someone like i i
could i could feel that energy because
like i've been to like places before
where you talk to the bouncer and they
explain to you like look look like
it's full mate there's nothing i can do
you know like i don't i don't know i i
would be like trying to help you yeah
i'd be like i get it because i'm like
i'm a human as well but like
i was like he was like nah gotta
prioritize our members and i was looking
around i was like thinking
what [ __ ] members
it's you and me i was like there is no
line here there is no line there's no
line of people waiting to come up i know
for a fact uh because after i went in
the casino was like 90 empty so i was
just like what i was just like you know
this is an [ __ ] being an [ __ ] and
this is like the the only thing that
could beat an [ __ ] is a carron and
like
unstoppable force
you know those youtube videos where
they're like yeah just like bribe your
way into everything you don't have yeah
you're like oh you wanna you want an
upgrade at a hotel room just slip the
person 50 bucks yeah i've always thought
about stuff like that because i'm like
i'd love to be able to have the
slickness and the coolness to pull that
[ __ ] off but i'm just thinking like how
do i how do i
discreetly just give you like 10 pounds
in a way that like doesn't make me look
[ __ ] stupid yeah yeah
what if you say no to me right and then
i'm like oh give me a second you pull
out ten notes
i come in please please like can i come
in now like yeah surely i would have to
preemptively give him some money and
that point what if no one else paid
money to get in and i'm the [ __ ] who
gave him 10 pounds yeah and
alternatively what if you go to like
that whole i see all those [ __ ] tick
tocks just give your hotel check
checking person 50 bucks like it's like
okay what if the hotel's just actually
full like you actually just gave them
fifty dollars and you're dead i've seen
that before though where like i saw a
guy at like a a club or like a bar or
something yeah who like you know did
like the whole [ __ ] being like like
pulls out a 20 and like puts it into the
you know bounces like pocket yeah and
the bouncer looks at it and he's like
all right give me something i'm gonna go
talk to the manager about it yeah and he
goes in he comes out and he's like sorry
we're full
and then everyone in the lines just
starts laughing being like i want to dig
in i've seen it work and not work yeah
yeah yeah yeah i've seen when it doesn't
work it's hilarious yeah yeah yeah but
that's that to me it's like all right
the the benefits don't outweigh the the
absolute humility of getting projected
yeah yeah yeah trying to offer money to
someone to get into something yeah it's
like you not only lost money but you
also didn't get what you wanted yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah there's some people
who like have the i think they have the
personality that matches up to that kind
of behavior oh yeah
i'm not slick at all i cannot do this
stuff i can't do that i've been with
guys who are just like well let's uh
let's come to a solution and then they
like [ __ ] give the tempo
i've not seen jen do it but i thought
jen would
at least like
like jan has the energy that he could
pull it off no john has the energy you
can pull it off without ever getting his
wallet out yeah
he's just like let's talk
jen would do it get rejected and then
not care that he was rejected yeah just
be like okay we'll go somewhere else
yeah but to me it's like that's crushing
inbound i can't do that you tell me it's
full i don't have a magical karen that
appears to sort it out for me i guess i
don't have like
a cool cat
i don't have like a stand i can pull up
i guess i'm done
yeah because like i just go for trying
to be a clown a little bit maybe i'll
feel like oh that was funny i'll let
this go yeah i try and like i try and
like humor my way through things because
it doesn't work there's no idea the
thing about those bribes i've seen is
just like how do you how do you know how
much to give you know like like how like
how what's the right amount to bribe
someone of like well if you're trying to
get into like
a you know a michelin star restaurant i
i don't know how that would work doesn't
make any sense but like a club if
there's a [ __ ] club maybe you just give
them like i don't know i've got six pins
two drinks in there yeah many people who
do this often know
i don't know there's like a t list all
right yeah maybe they can explain it to
me how it works but yeah how nice or
expensive the drinks are yeah i've never
heard of being rejected from a casino
that's and only like drunk people get
rejected from casinos normally
were you tipsy
i was not
like dan's telling this story while he
was like two bottles of tv like that
wall
others
[Laughter]
yeah
yeah
that was a good night we uh we we went
to casino it was it was a happy end to
the story uh
it was the one time in my life that uh
seeing someone go go for karen uh was
impressive and it actually worked as
well
not that i would ever have the balls to
do almost no i i i was just standing
there um and i was just i was impressed
that's what everyone needs though yeah
like not ever like you you don't need to
be a karen you just need to know what
karen yeah that's that's all you need
you just need that one mate who will be
the best to be a champion for when they
work for me
parents karen suck unless you can tell
them to do something that you wanted no
no no
unless
the the manager or the person is being
an equal [ __ ] yeah
you know like i i normally i don't
advocate for this like at all because
you know service people go through
enough you know so you go through people
when people i see videos people like
arguing at mcdonald's for free food
what happened
at birth that you became like this like
how did you how are you dropped hard
enough yeah to go to a mcdonald's and
like berate a 14 year old kid just like
being a brat about it all right like
they're probably a brat their entire
life there are early very few points and
some well then like yeah if if the
service person is being an [ __ ] yes
you should be a coward even though i
still don't have it in me even if they
mean
there have been plenty of points where
i'm like i should go for karen you know
because there have been plenty of points
where they have been the [ __ ] yeah
and i'm totally within my rights to go
full carrot but like it's just
it's just so hard man it's it's so hard
luckily google reviews exist
i mean you know like that [ __ ] who
ordered the 20b 20b52s i would have
loved to have like snapped back at him
yeah but i just i could have made it
yeah yeah i didn't have the balls yeah
or or when you well when they tell you
you have to you get charged four
thousand dollars change your ticket
absolutely absolute stale absolute steak